[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Thank
you so much for coming
to this session, Speeding
Up Research in Genomics.
My name is Jonathan Sheffi.
I'm the product
manager at Google Cloud
for biomedical data, including
genomics, gene expression,
and so on.
So really excited about
our panelists here today.
We've got panelists from
Duke, Michigan, and Stanford.
And before we get
to their talks,
I'm just going tell you a
little bit about the team
that I'm a part of; a couple
of important announcements,
in case you missed
them yesterday;
and tell you a little bit about
what my team is working on.
So I'm part of a team called the
Cloud for Healthcare and Life
Sciences team.
We are a set of product
managers, engineers,
solution architects,
and go-to-market
that are focused on how we can
help in healthcare and life
sciences, build things
into Google Cloud
that our industry
will find useful
and increase the
scale of their work.
Within the product
team, we're focused on
not just genomic data,
not just biomedical data,
but everything.
How do we help make medical
imaging data more useful
through, for example, our Dicom
API which helps you structure
imaging metadata in BigQuery?
You may have heard this
week that our healthcare
API launched to alpha,
helping provider systems more
effectively manage
their clinical data.
And one of the things that's
really exciting about this kind
of work is what it enables us to
unlock when more and more data
is coming to the Cloud.
The other announcement
you may have
heard about in Diane Greene's
keynote yesterday morning
was our new partnership with the
National Institutes of Health.
Under this really
groundbreaking partnership,
we will be making many of
the high-value public and
controlled access
datasets that are
funded by the NIH available
to users of Google Cloud.
So this will include many of
the datasets that are already
working with and now
will no longer need
to worry about needing to find
space in your data center for.
I actually have kind
of a story about this.
A few years ago, I was sitting
at a research university
that will remain nameless.
And in the meeting,
there were three PIs
at one end of the
table, and there
was a head of
research and computing
at the other end of the table.
And over the course
of the discussions,
we were learning about the
work that they were doing.
It turned out that
each of the PIs
had separately downloaded
their own copy of 1000 Genomes.
I see some smiles
of recognition.
This may have happened to you.
You may have seen this happen.
And if I looked at the
other end of the table,
I saw a research
computing director
whose face was basically
melting realizing
how much data was being
duplicated and stored
in their data center.
And so these are some of
the problems that we're
trying to solve both
by democratizing access
to data for researchers
but also solving
some of these operational
excellence problems
for research IT leaders at
universities and other folks
doing biomedical research.
And it also sets us up to build
some really fantastic products,
so I'm going to tell
you about, for example,
one of the products
from my own team.
One of the things we've built
is called Variant Transforms.
It's an open source tool.
You can find it on GitHub.
Not only is the code online,
not only are the docs online,
but our roadmap is online.
So please feel free
to vote on the issues.
And what Variant
Transforms does,
it's a tool that lets you take
your VCF data, your processed
genome data, and import
it directly to BigQuery.
BigQuery's an incredible
tool, a managed data warehouse
solution.
One of my colleagues
mentioned I think it stores
13 copies of the web every day.
So it's an incredible
data warehouse,
and we're setting it up so
that you can use BigQuery
to manage your variant data.
So what does this
mean in practice?
I want to tell you
about a company called
Color Genomics who are actually
right here in the Bay Area.
They're a health
services company.
They provide affordable
genetic testing
focused in breast cancer.
You may have heard of them.
So they've got this
30-gene panel in cancer.
And they also had, separately,
an existing database
of phenotypic data,
health information data,
and so on about
all these samples
have come through their lab.
And they've got the VCF data.
They've got this
Postgres database
of phenotypic information.
I said, what can we do here?
If there's a genotype
to phenotype problem,
we could probably investigate.
And they looked at existing
cloud providers that
will remain nameless,
that are not Google Cloud,
and they found they really
didn't have the data warehouse
solution that they
were looking for
to be able to handle
this kind of a problem.
And so they used
Variant Transforms,
this tool that I mentioned.
They were able to import
all of that genomic data
directly into BigQuery.
They used the
BigQuery import tool
to bring in all the
phenotypic data.
And their data scientists
were able to stand up
a set of machine learning
tools on top of that integrated
joined dataset.
So what happened?
They were able to do all the
feature engineering in one
week, actually during
their quarterly company
Hack Week, where they get to
work on whatever they want.
And they were able
to create models
that dramatically outperformed
an existing clinical model.
They were actually able to
show that this 30-gene cancer
panel was able to predict a
biomarker not in cancer, which
is a publishable
result-- pretty exciting
and possibly a product
opportunity for the company.
More importantly, it
really transformed them
from thinking about themselves
as a lab company that
just makes VCFs, much like
maybe the informatics cores
at your own institutions, and
think about themselves more
as a data organization,
where they're really
doing data mining.
And that's because
of Google Cloud.
All right, you didn't
come to just listen to me.
I want to introduce our
fantastic panelists.
So we're hearing from Alex
Waldrop and Razvan Panea
from Duke University,
and then Jonathan LeFaive
from the University of Michigan,
and finally, Sowmi Utiramerur--
I think I got that right--
from Stanford University.
I'm so excited to hear what
they've got to share with us.
And to lead us off,
Alex and Razvan.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX WALDROP: Thank
you, Jonathan,
for that introduction.
Today, I want to talk to you
all a little bit about what
our lab is doing in scaling
up to the challenge of cancer
genomics with Google Cloud
and a software package
that we've created
called CloudConductor.
I'm going to tell you something
about the state of cancer
research that you may not know.
Although we've made tremendous
progress in the past 50 years
on understanding how cancers
arise and how to treat them,
we've only scratched the
surface in understanding
the true diversity
of the known cancer
types that are in existence.
So for instance, the
World Health Organization
identified--
or currently recognizes
over 1,000 cancer types.
We have good data on
maybe 200 of those.
So the next decades, we'll
be filling in those knowledge
gaps.
And part of that is
with cancer genomics,
and the state of cancer
genomics actually
lags even further behind.
So take for example the
Cancer Genome Atlas,
TCGA, which Jonathan
just mentioned.
But in that original study,
it took them eight years.
They sequenced 10,000
tumors but just
from 13 different cancer types.
So we have good sequence
data and genomic data
on less than 1% of
the known cancers.
Our lab's goal is simple, and
that is to systematically study
the genomics of all cancers.
Now before you laugh so
hard that you fall out
of your chair, I want
to say a claim that's
going to be even more
audacious, and that is our goal
is to do that within
the next five years.
Now, we're making
progress towards that.
So this past year
in a pilot study
that we did published in "Cell,"
we looked at 1,000 tumors
from a single lymphoma
subtype called DLBCL.
But eventually, that
goal is to scale up
to 100,000 tumors sequenced
from each of those 1,000
cancers represented.
How are we making
strides on that?
Well, first off we
did the hard work,
and we founded a
worldwide consortium
of over 30 leading
academic hospitals
from around the world.
So these are helping us
gather patients, enroll them
in the studies so
that we can have
the diversity of cancer types
represented in that data set.
We've also created a
collaborative Cloud-based
system for collating, collecting
that metadata and those tumors.
So we can store things
like pathology data
and pathology reviews.
Eventually, we'll
be able to link up
that metadata with
the genomic data
and understand how patient
outcomes are being influenced
by patient genotypes.
But the more tangible goal that
we'll be reaching this year
is sequencing
10,000 blood cancers
from over 100 different
lymphoma subtypes.
Now, why blood cancers?
For one, they're the number one
in terms of cancer diagnosis
and treatment across cancers.
For two, with over 100 types,
they're extremely diverse.
And basically, we'll be
knocking out about 10%
of our goal of all cancers
by just sequencing this one
category.
So we've already enrolled
more than 10,000 patients
in the study and have collected
more than 10,000 tumor samples.
And we've already begun exome
and transcriptome sequencing
on this project.
But a bigger
question is, how can
a group of four
bioinformaticians
do in four months
what it took TCGA
and their hundreds of
bioinformaticians almost eight
years to do, and that
is to sequence 10,000
genomes at the same time?
And maybe to understand
how we're saving time,
it would be a better
lesson to talk
about why it is so
time-consuming to sequence
a genome in order to make
those kind of breakthroughs.
So it would be really great
if a DNA sequencer was
a machine that
picked up a genome
and let you read it
end-to-end, like a book.
That actually doesn't exist.
In practice, a DNA sequencer
is a little bit more
like a shredder and that
you put the book into,
and it rips it into
a billion pieces
that you get back and
have to assemble later.
So in order to read
that story from that bag
of a billion pieces--
and by reading this
story in our case,
it is identifying a variant
that may be underlying a cancer.
But in any case, the
process of assembling
a bag of a billion
slices of paper
back into an original book
or reassembling a genome
is very computationally
expensive
and operationally complex.
It usually involves 15
or 20 third-party tools
being strung together in what
we call a biological pipeline.
And this is basically
where you're
piping the output
from one program
into the output of another.
They have different versions.
Each of them has their
own runtime environment.
It's a real pain in the butt to
try to get these things going.
And so from a
computing perspective,
the ad hoc approaches
that people generally use
are not reproducible.
They are time-consuming.
And they're very error-prone.
And so that's why we are using
and created CloudConductor
to help solve those
challenges on our way
to the 10,000 and even
100,000 genomes goal.
And to talk about
how CloudConductor
is doing that, I'm going to turn
it over to my colleague, Razvan
Panea, here.
RAZVAN PANEA: Thank you, Alex.
CloudConductor is a Cloud-based
bioinformatics workflow
management system.
We developed
CloudConductor to address
the four central
challenges in biocomputing.
The first challenge
for computing
is diversity, as many
analysis pipelines in research
use different bioinformatics
tools in different orders.
So we implemented a system
that allows the researcher
to run any pipeline.
Secondly, scalability is a
problem in bioinformatics,
as the input sample size
is continuously increasing,
and the institutional computing
resources are limited.
Fortunately, cloud
computing platforms,
such as Google
Cloud, are actually
a solution to this problem.
Furthermore, the total cost of
processing is also a problem.
However, we managed
to fix this issue
by using preemtable
instances from a cloud.
And finally,
portability is actually
a very serious problem,
as data analysis
needs to be reproducible.
However, we're using
Docker technology
to containerize the
tools in the pipelines.
So the researcher can run
the same pipeline anywhere
without having to worry about
affecting the final output.
After solving these
challenges, CloudConductor
has become a comprehensive
workflow management system
that works in three big phases.
The first phase is represented
by the researcher selecting
from a list of predefined and
user-defined bioinformatics
tools to generate an analysis
workflow after which,
CloudConductor conductor
validates, or interprets,
this workflow.
In the next phase,
CloudConductor
obtains these tools and runs
them in the correct order
by allocating the
necessary resources
on a cloud-computing platform,
such as Google Cloud,
and by generating a processing
environment using the Docker
system.
After the analysis is
complete, CloudConductor
could transfer the
[INAUDIBLE] statistics
to a database and
the final output
to an actual cloud
storage system,
such as Google Cloud Storage.
Now, in order for our lab
to use the CloudConductor,
we implement an additional
infrastructure layer that fully
automates this entire system.
The system starts from
the moment the sequencing
data enters our lab.
At the click of
one single button,
we update the database,
our lab database,
with the new
sequencing information.
And almost immediately
after that,
CloudConductor
daemon, as service
that we implemented, and
continuously waits and watches
the database identifies
the new additions
and generates a new
instance of CloudConductor
on Google Cloud Platform.
And after a short
period of time,
after the analysis is
complete, CloudConductor
reports the status of the
analysis to the lab database,
and the final output files
that we'll look later
are transferred to
Google Cloud storage.
And as you can observe,
overall, the system
is not only fully-automated,
but it can also be reproducible.
And as a proof of concept,
we used an early version
of this pipeline of
the system to process
a large cohort of
1,000 lymphoma patients
that was published in "Cell."
And in the future,
we're planning
to use this system to increase
the sample size not only by 10
times but even 100 times.
Before I close, I would
like to acknowledge
our lab, [INAUDIBLE] Dave, a
co-developer of CloudConductor.
And in conclusion,
CloudConductor
is helping our lab
create the largest cancer
datasets in the world.
Using the right
tools, cloud computing
helps small labs, like ours,
do data analysis at the highest
institutional skill level.
And using all these
systems, we're
able to get faster
breakthroughs,
develop better treatments, and
get closer and closer to curing
the disease that we study.
We'll take questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, I'd like to
introduce Jonathan LeFaive
from University of Michigan.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN LEFAIVE: Thank you,
and good morning, everyone.
I suspect most of you have heard
of the term precision medicine.
The idea is to provide medical
treatments and screenings that
are tailored to an individual's
unique characteristics.
Take high cholesterol,
for example--
LDL cholesterol, which is often
referred to as bad cholesterol,
can build up in your arteries,
resulting in heart disease.
The usual cause of this is
unhealthy lifestyle choices
pertaining to diet and exercise.
But sometimes, this
can be inherited.
One gene responsible for
this is called PCSK9.
This gene produces a troublesome
enzyme of the same name.
This enzyme binds to naturally
occurring LDL receptors,
preventing these receptors from
removing the bad cholesterol.
After discovering this, PCSK9
inhibitors were developed.
These are drugs that
neutralized the enzymes'
effect on cholesterol levels.
But the treatment won't be
equally effective for everyone.
Rare mutations in this gene
can either make it overactive
or knock out its
activity altogether.
But by looking at a patient's
DNA, it's possible for doctors
to determine whether or
not these inhibitors would
be the most effective
treatment for their patient.
This is an example of a genetic
defect that we do know about,
but there's still
plenty to be learned
before precision medicine
can reach its full potential.
The National Heart,
Lung, and Blood Institute
is sponsoring a project
called TOPMed that is focused
on closing this knowledge gap.
But for projects like
this to study DNA,
they must first collect DNA.
A traditional method
for this is using
what is called a microarray.
It targets small
subsets of the genome,
supplying researchers with
tens to hundreds of thousands
of genetic markers to analyze.
This technique is
relatively inexpensive,
which makes it attractive
for use in both research
and consumer services, like
23andMe and ancestry.com.
And while this method is useful
for targeting common variations
of DNA, it lacks
the scope needed
to find rare associations
like those in PCSK9.
For this, we need to
use a method called
whole genome sequencing, which
looks at the entire genome.
With this process, a
lab physically sequences
short, accurate reads of DNA.
These reads are
then algorithmically
aligned, or mapped,
to a reference genome
and include a lot of
overlap, or depth,
to ensure that what
we're seeing in the data
isn't due to random error.
The TOPMed initiative is
employing this technique
with 130,000 individuals and
has produced data sets up
to 600 million variants--
in other words, 600
million potential avenues
for discovery.
40% of these are extremely
rare and have likely never
been seen before.
Only with this level
of information can
we study how rare mutations
are associated with disease.
Now, at this point, some of
you may be thinking, well,
that's great.
But what does this have
to do with Google Cloud?
So going forward,
I'm going to talk
about the technical challenges
of whole genome sequencing,
how and why we leverage Google
Cloud Platform to surmount
these challenges, and how the
Cloud is helping us foster
collaboration in the research.
So here's how whole genome
sequencing breaks down in terms
of data size and compute.
At the scale of
TOPMed, it produces
approximately three petabytes
of highly-compressed sequence
data.
And mapping these reads
takes around 6,000 core years
to compute.
That is a long time to
wait, and we haven't even
gotten the science yet.
At the University
of Michigan, we
are warehousing, mapping, and
generating aggregate datasets
of TOPMed data so that
the genomes can be
used in association analyzes.
Using our local cluster which
has a few thousand cores,
it would take years to tackle
this amount of sequence data.
But with the seemingly limitless
resources on Google Compute
Engine, we can compress a
couple of years of data prep
into a few months.
This means researchers can
start analyzing the data
and making discoveries
much sooner.
This convenience
does come at a cost,
and researchers tend to
have limited budgets.
But there are a
couple of features
which go beyond simply having
competitive prices that
make Google Cloud Platform
stand out in this regard.
Unlike other cloud providers
that restrict users
to predefined machine
types, Compute Engine
is completely modular,
allowing resource allocations
that meet the exact
needs of a given task.
These fine-tuned controls
allow those of us
with limited budgets to
maximize every penny.
The preemptal machines can
take those cost savings
even further.
As many of you already, GCP
offers their idle resource
reserves at a fraction of
the costs but with the caveat
that they can be preempted
or taken away at any moment.
In order to reduce the
time lost from preemption,
we have altered our pipelines
to be more resilient.
We've done this by chunking
our compute jobs into smaller
pieces and
checkpointing the output
files into Cloud storage.
With this approach, we can
still make progress, even
when preemption occurs.
Cloud storage is also
serving another purpose.
TOPMed is a collaboration
of approximately 30 studies
across many institutions.
Each study has focused
expertise in diseases
such as asthma, sickle cell
disease, atrial fibrillation,
and heart disease.
Making these
discoveries requires
a diverse knowledge
base, so genomic datasets
like these have traditionally
been distributed to the experts
to be analyzed in
our local clusters.
But this is becoming
more and more
difficult to handle as
the data sizes increase,
especially for smaller labs.
The National
Institute of Health is
piloting an ecosystem
using TOPMed data following
a different approach.
Instead of sending
data to the scientist,
we are bringing the
scientists to the data.
It's called the
NIH Data Commons,
and it will empower researchers
from institutions of all sizes
to form high-throughput
computations
within Google's platform.
But even within this space, data
access needs to be regulated.
When DNA is donated,
it is often given
with specific consent
that determine
what it can be used for, and
these consents vary widely
from study to study.
The Data Commons is building
frameworks for access control
on top of the existing
cloud storage APIs,
and we're doing this to
ensure that these consents are
respected.
These frameworks range from
programmatically generating
signed URLs to fuse
file system limitations
that turn buckets
into a mounted disk.
Google Cloud's Container
Support is another great feature
for this type of environment.
Scientists love containers,
and it's not just
because it's easy to deploy
complicated pipelines
but because it makes
it easier for peers
to reproduce your work.
And reproducibility is
critical in science.
Google's private
container [? repos ?]
are backed by Cloud Storage.
This allows for bloated
container images
to be pooled more quickly.
And just like typical
objects in Cloud Storage,
access controls can be applied,
allowing you to safely share
images that contain sensitive
health or genetic information.
So by leveraging the
Cloud in these ways,
we can scale to unprecedented
levels of data storage
and compute, allowing us to and
make discoveries more quickly.
We can bring
researchers together
to work on a level playing field
and in a highly-collaborative
environment.
And in doing so, we can quicken
the pace of medical progress.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Up next, we have the
Director of Bioinformatics
at Stanford University,
Sowmi Utiramerur.
SOWMI UTIRAMERUR:
Thanks, Jonathan.
Morning, everyone.
I'm Sowmi.
As any true academic
will do, I've
collected multiple titles which
I will not bore you with today.
But in essence, my role
is to drive adoption
of genomics in medicine.
Jonathan already mentioned
about precision medicine.
So what does
precision medicine--
since I made pretty
slides with light bulbs,
I'm going to
reiterate the point.
[LAUGHTER]
We take genomic sequencing
data of the patient.
We combine with sequencing
data from other patients
with similar disease
or disorders,
even healthy individuals,
for that matter.
We analyze them together with
all available annotations,
or publicly-available
annotations,
to come up with a precise
diagnosis for that patient.
And finally, we tailor the
treatment not just based
on the disease but to the
particular genetic makeup
of the patient
that is a concern.
So in essence, we are trying
to be Starbucks for medicine.
So at Stanford, our
mission is to deliver
on the promise of precision
medicine for all our patients.
And we do so by using
genomic sequencing.
Primarily, we are focused
on childhood rare diseases,
inherited cancer, cardio,
and neurological disorders.
So that's the promise of
precision medicine, but what
are the challenges?
So there are several challenges,
principal among which
is that we have
yet to understand
the regulatory mechanisms
of many of the genes
and how their functions
correlate at a more-- the
pathways level.
But there are more
mundane or fundamental
challenges which we
are yet to overcome,
and principal among which,
as Jonathan mentioned,
repeatability and
reproducibility,
which is paramount when
you're using anything
in a diagnostic setting.
So if you're a diabetic,
you're taking a blood test
to measure your sugar levels.
If the instrument gives two
widely different measurements
at different times
it makes measurement,
you're not going
to rely on that.
Genetic tests are
extremely complex,
primarily because we use
multiple instruments, hundreds
of different analytical
methods which
runs on different hardware
platforms, whether it
be laptop, in-house
cluster, or on the Cloud.
But yet, we are expected to
reproduce the same result not
just on a given day but up
to two years into the future.
And the second biggest
point, as-- that everybody
and the other panelists
mentioned-- is security.
Anybody who has done
anything on the Cloud
is primarily worried
about data security.
And this is extremely important
when you put patient health
information on the Cloud.
This essentially gives
people fits and makes
us lose sleep every night.
But how do we overcome
these challenges?
Primarily with the help of
container-optimized engine
virtual machines from Google.
And HIPAA compatibility
and certification
of all GCP components helps
us achieve this goal much more
easily and removes
the heavy lift
of maintaining this hardware
from small clinical labs,
like us, which essentially,
we are not experts in.
So here is the example of how
we have solved it in Stanford.
You already heard about
Docker, which is essentially
crucial for reproducibility.
We have our own
workflow manager.
Of course, we have
to have our own.
We cannot just use others'.
So ours is called LOOM,
which essentially understands
workflow language, pulls
in the Docker container
that you need for
execution step,
imports all the
files that is needed,
hashes them to make sure that
the files have not changed.
If so, it warns that
the workflow is not
reproducible at the
end of the execution,
shuts down the VM, and
copies all the files back
to the specified storage.
This way, we can ship off the
container and the workflow
language to any institution, and
they can reproduce the results.
But let's get to
a bigger problem.
And the bigger problem
is that any genetic test,
the average diagnostic
yield is around 30%.
Of course, for certain diseases,
it's much higher than 30%,
and for certain, it's lower.
But what do we mean by that?
For all the patients that walk
in with a genetic disorder
into our lab, we are able to
give a precise diagnosis only,
for on average, 30%
of the cases, which
we have to improve upon.
So I'll give you two specific
patient study examples
in the next couple of
slides to highlight
the importance of
adopting novel sequencing
methods, analytical methods,
and data mining and data sharing
in order to be able to improve
upon the set diagnostic yield.
So the first example
is a patient case
with Carney complex with cardiac
myxoma, which is-- essentially,
Carney complex leads to benign
tumors in different issue
types, primarily skin.
But when it gets
too hard, it leads
to weakening of our valves
and ultimately requiring
a heart transplant.
So this is a patient case.
We had a suspicion that--
this is a genetic disorder.
We know the gene
that causes this.
But we sequenced it.
We could not find
the change that
was causal in this patient.
So in addition to giving them
a short-read sequencing, which
we typically do
for all patients,
we used a new technology
called long-read sequencing
from PacBio, which
led us to identify
a long deletion,
two-exon deletion,
in this gene, which
is deleted in one
copy of the gene
versus the other, which
makes it much more
harder to find
with short-read sequencing.
And we had to develop normal
sequencing methods in order
to be able to analyze this data.
And this is where
the contribution
of Google AI and
Google Genomics,
like Deep Gradient
from [INAUDIBLE],,
is very critical for us
to be able to advance
this process of being
able to identify
novel genetic gradients,
which we were not
able to do otherwise.
And second example
highlights the importance
of data sharing and data mining.
This is a case of
two siblings affected
with several neurological
phenotypes, primarily delayed
intellectual development,
cerebellar ataxia, which is,
essentially, you lose
control of your muscles,
atrophy of the brain itself.
So we sequenced these patients.
In this case, we found a
mutation in the SNX14 gene,
but we just involved our--
implicated in brain development
in mouse models.
But we're not seeing this
in any other patients,
so we weren't sure whether
this was the real cause
of the mutation or not.
But purely by chance, we
identified another patient
in the sidelines
of a conference,
like this, that another patient
who had the same symptoms
and the same mutation
in that gene, which
led us to conclude that this
is the true causal gradient
in this gene for
this patient, which
ended a 10-year diagnostic
odyssey for these patients.
In most of these cases,
these are not curable,
but just finding the
cause of a disease
is so much help
for these patients,
that there's a hope,
at least, that there is
a cure for them in the future.
So the importance of this
data binding or data sharing
is really important, because
these are rare diseases where
only a handful of people
and handful of mutations
are found in genes like this.
So finally, I would
like to conclude
by raising the
importance of platforms
like Google Cloud and other--
I think, even though it's
not in their core business,
the contributions
made by Google AI
and Google Genomics helps drive
genomics research much forward
and being able to adapt this in
precision medicine a whole lot
faster.
With that, I'd like to thank
everyone and invite Jonathan
back for Q&A.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN SHEFFI: Thanks so much.
All right, thank you all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]